Texas is trying to counter America's
border crisis with a big show of force
there members of the Texas National
Guard have been deployed along with
heavy duty equipment to help keep
migrants out amid fears of a major spike
in Asylum Seekers if a pandemic area
error policy is allowed to expire Omar
via Franca is in El Paso Texas which has
declared a migrant emergency Omar good
morning to you
good morning another night with
temperatures in the 30s and 30s and this
hundreds of migrants sleeping in and
outside of shelters in El Paso on the
other side of the Border Mexican police
are now enforcing a rule where they're
keeping migrants away from the
Riverbanks but on the U.S side 400 New
National Guard soldiers in a new show
Force
in just the past 24 hours it's become a
much different scene here along the U.S
Mexico border
from behind razor wire National Guard
troops armed with rifles and bull horns
tell migrants who just crossed onto U.S
soil they cannot enter this way
[Music]
killing the migrants
being on this side is illegal you have
to leave the troops here are directing
them to an official entry point but the
migrants we spoke to say even there
border patrol agents are turning them
away unsure where to go it's adding even
more confusion to what's already been an
uncertain and dangerous journey across
the river and ciudad Juarez Mexico
yanisi Martinez looks on in despair
it took the 27 year old three months to
get this far traveling from Venezuela
with her three young children she says
to escape violence and poverty as she
tries to get to her brother in North
Carolina
but after spotting the armed men she
says she's scared and desperate her
youngest is now sick with a fever
despite the uncertainty of ending title
42 the city of El Paso is putting plans
in motion to take care of as many as 10
000 Asylum Seekers turning empty middle
schools into shelters
but back across the border in Mexico the
mother of three is at a loss with
nowhere to sleep and temperatures
dropping
all she wants is an opportunity to get
in
DHS has moved nearly 10 000 migrants out
of El Paso a third of them were actually
expelled under title 42 the other two
thirds were taken to other cities so
they can further process their
immigration claims Tony okay Omar thank
you very much tough story there